Mother's Day is coming up of course just
a couple of weeks and Andy I hear you
started a service to help people find a
special gift for Mother's Day that right
yeah I did Cohn and I mean mothers do so
much for us and it's so important that
we honor them on their special day
take a look every Mother's Day you wait
until the very last minute then panic
and wind up getting mom a thoughtless
impersonal gift
well now you can save yourself the
stress and worry and pre-order that
thoughtless impersonal gift today modest
expectations has a wide selection of
gifts that say obligation met with
Mother's Day classics like dusty Yankee
Candle monks with her name almost
spelled right sticky discount bash sets
Applebee's gift cards CVS brand
compression size full movies Reba
McEntire's signature perfume and war
just place the order on our website and
we'll do the rest when your mom sees the
modest expectations box she'll know
she's about to say and guarantee
delivery note earlier than 9:00 p.m. on
Mother's Day any earlier and I wouldn't
think it was my kid - expectations puts
in the bare minimum for you so you can
get back to your busy life not as
expectations when you care enough to do
the very least
he knows I don't have feet anymore
but that sketch had some button at the
end in it like Dahlia really feeling it
you